[Music]
hostas are coming up and you are the
consummate showbiz dude and I love when
you use language phonics tapes has
really paid off no idea where I was
going but you're such a show you still
don't know I really don't but going to
the Oscars is that something that you
like to do well I was bitter at first
because I thought okay no nomination and
then autonomy I guess you have to have
made a movie I don't know I I mean I
haven't seen a lot of films I thought
Iron Maiden was a bit of vibrator I
don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
I thought midnight in Paris was a sex
tape with a Hilton girl
[Applause]
I have won many awards of course I hate
to talk about me all the time but you
really you have you must have won
countless awards well I've won a Tony
Award many Emmys - daytime Oscars and
and six n-double-a-cp Image Awards that
I still throw a party from Morgan feat I
know we brought up Steve Martin earlier
but your life you're surrounded by
slippers you have a lot of clothes
celebrity pals I'm talking big a-listers
now who like who like tug game ooh yes I
see you out on the town with Clark Gable
Lana Turner Lana is wonderful if she
would not go out with that Johnny
Stompanato no listen touring to college
campus I had a fun experience on New
Year's Eve day I actually ran into Frank
smiley one of your producers mm-hmm and
but Tom Hanks I saw Tom in the local
pharmacy in the Palisades we were very
good friends and I went up behind him he
was like kind of looking at pins he
always buys pins and I went up behind
him and just breathed on his neck was me
and then with the two of us got in my
car and we went to Gelson's because I
decided to make a French punch for
Christmas on this for the moment you and
Tom Hanks together go to a supermarket
yeah and when we were shopping through
the supermarket he kept saying you see
this would be like if we had an
apartment I've been pushing the cart but
anyway
anyway I was uh this is just again true
we were it was very crowded at Gelson's
and I couldn't get a parking spot and
Tom's talking and and I'm I see if one
guy pulling out so I thought oh I'll get
in there and I pull up and I smash into
another car this routing and it's
amazing you know I'm going like two
miles an hour
major damage to my mater and he I get
out and he gets out and he sees me and
he goes oh well I guess I don't need to
see your ID and then Tom walked out
mm-hmm and he was stunned and by the
time I got my insurance out I heard the
guy saying you don't have to read the
whole script but just listen to the
music
[Applause]
we have a definitely want to show this
clip do we have time for this clip
because this is from a special that you
did Martin Short Martin Short goes home
hi Martin Short goes home and I got to
watch it last night
it is absolutely hilarious like really
funny and this is a I think a clip I
don't know which one this is but I think
I believe this is an operatic version of
your birth yes this is a celebration of
my birth let's take a look
my son my boy
today
[Music]
[Music]
all right who just made us stinky in
their pants wig in that scene is the
great and brilliant Andrea Martin Martin
yes you know what there's no one funnier
thank you so much so by the time you're
a great man Martin Short